So, Neil, the reason I wanted to bring
you out here is to show you just how
different corn and teosinte are. Yeah.
This is a teosinte plant and it doesn't
look anything like a typical corn plant.
And you can start by just looking down
at the base, it just branches a lot, so
it is a very bushy creature and quite
different from corn plants, such as you
see here, where there's just a single
main stock, no branches, except for
these two short branches, each of which
has an ear on it. The dramatic
difference in branching between
teosinte and maize is just the
beginning. When you look at an ear of
corn, you can see hundreds of kernels
exposed on the cob. But teosinte is
different. Each ear only has a handful
of kernels, each enclosed in a fruit
case that's so hard you might crack a
tooth if you tried to eat it.